il n'y a aucun doute pour la commission
denquête l'asu du capitole était une
tentative de coup d'état fomenté par nul
autre que dans notre chambre
images documents témoignages à l'appui
il décortique minute par minute le
déroulement de cette journée fatidique
un des témoins le documentariste nick x
side film et la milice des plats aux
boys ce jour là
dès 10 heures avant le discours de dans
notre chambre le groupe se dirigeait
déjà vers le capitole
je n'ai pas le droit de vous dire ce qui
va se passer dit elle mais il va se
passer quelque chose
tous diront plus tard qu'ils répondaient
à l'appel lancé par dans nos chambres
on a été invité par le président des
états unis eurent l'un des manifestants
et c'est ce que plusieurs d'entre eux
diront à la commission at-elle
d'horrible et j'ai cru que ces élections
étaient volés dit il et chante nous a
demandé de venir une chambre
je savais pourquoi j'étais là dit il
c'est parce qu'il m'avait demandé d'être
là
nous sommes du même côté ne nous forcez
pas être contre vous dit il aux
policiers des images rythmée par des
extraits du discours de deurne
hautes-chaumes ce jour là le jour où la
démocratie à vassy aux états unis une
dernière photo avant l'assaut sur
tripoli selon un des enquêteurs tout
ceci était planifié depuis la victoire
de joe biden le leader des eaux
skippeuse avait écrit à ses membres nous
n'allons pas laisser passer ça sent une
guerre civile
on apprend également que le soir du 5
janvier le leader des pros de briser
celui des hausses qui pèsent sur drogue
s'étaient rencontrés dans un
stationnement souterrain à washington
eisenstein semaine le mahb le président
chant pas convoquer la foule est allumé
la mèche de l'attak dit elle
après ce commentaire de dans notre
chambre lors du débat télévisé
le leader des plantes beau il répond
nous sommes prêts à
vous que le nombre de profs boys a
augmenté après demande l'enquêteur sa
triple et repenti
on apprend aussi que l'entourage dans
notre chambre incluant sa fille était en
désaccord avec l'idée que les élections
ont été volés
je n'étais pas d'accord avec lui dix
sont l'ancien ministre de la justice
je lui ai dit que c'est de la foutaise
et plus facteurs a affecté ma
perspective renchérit 24 chambres
déchaîné une fervente républicaine
lancent un message fort à ses collègues
sinaï à mes collègues républicains
dit-elle qui défendent l'indéfendable
un jour viendra où dans notre chum sera
parti et votre déshonneur lui restera
joe biden quand elle lui lance un
avertissement
jakes women's world today les mêmes
forces qui ont mené au 6 janvier dit ils
sont encore à l'oeuvre et c'est toute la
démocratie qui est en jeu
ici aux abords des gares guise
radio-canada washington